справжній поверх водкер і форми вона їх не
імітація сама теличок у it'sa сидні
експерти вид нового українського уряду
віджала шазза в дикій конкретній dia мола
витачки вони в кабінеті міністрів вдасться
завоювати до віри не чекаю народних
партнерів ще на і важливо
українців ситуація душа серйозна для
українець а так міг би це за 5 12 цього
дуже бажана що страви та кіу хвали
втіха нині розмір ковують над створ
трохи уряду знав і наскільки серйозно
щоб на вигляд побачили брала людей і
keys правді перуку він його вправо ж у
це цієї форми зрозуміють ах він взяти на
порядку деном і для нового кабміну
кілька в край важливий і для їх завдань за
крима фактично провалено реформу
прокуратури та суду вари форми базі для їх
на чоловіків його боротьба з корупцією
пріоритетом для нового господаря та
здивована грушевському
травня статуї така вже податкова реформа
прозрачна приватизація та децентралізація
у team за всю пораду з вигляду там і малюка
уряд алое президент кажуть експерти
виходить 6 гройсман людей на президента
порошенка у майбутньому вершини зможеш
з його таємниць та популярніші заходи на
прем'єра можна по melkco шкіряний ростер
ванні що земля ти мульти в майбутньому
вершини можна буде списати і на яку
сцепають бувай la якимось топер боятися
не кута син серця нюквіст
з по дивані і на новий і ряд ви лики про
ти його можливості та з цим ми ж не
призначають за сидні експерти а джен і моя
жадібний гарантії щоку а літія голосу в
Томазо всі реформаторські законопроекти
про ряд